I managed to keep this trip a complete secret
from the kids until last night
and I’ve been bursting with excitement
to tell them for months
because holidays like this are a rarity for our family
I was actually hoping to keep it a surprise until we got to the airport
but it turns out planning everything
packing everything and cleaning the house
for the housesitters
is a dead giveaway
think I freaked out a few people at the airport
by carrying around this baby doll
maybe I shouldn't have been holding it by
one leg upside down
my holiday read is a court of thorns and roses
and I know I'm late to the party
but I was skeptical okay
I thought surely it can't be as good as everybody says it is
but it is
it was late afternoon by the time we got to
beautiful Queenstown
and of course everybody was exhausted
I don't know what it is about travelling
but it's tiring so
we just wandered around the township for a
while before finding some dinner
at Sherwood this place is amazing
they grow most of their own produce
brew their own booze
and everything is locally sourced
we shared the slow roast lamb and some sides
before calling it a night early
because tomorrow is gonna be a busy day